et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis le royaume-uni avec baratin
pangkhan ya expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bon soit bad bank kenya merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
port du masque qui ne sera donc plus
obligatoire dans les lieux publics clos
à partir du 19 juillet plus de
distanciation sociale donc le variant
delta ne change pas la donne
saisi par cette décision n'est pas du
tout fondées sur la science nous avons
une augmentation des qualifications une
large partie de la population n'a pas
encore été vaccinés
il aurait donc été mieux de dire que
dans les yeux que les jeux ou jouets a
beaucoup de moi tout temps et lui
ressenti n'est il faudrait continuer à
porter le masque alors mal parti si
j'ose dire puisqu'il ya les demi finales
et la finale à wembley
est-ce que clairement ces événements
peuvent t'ils selon vous devenir le
nouveau scandale sanitaire
heureusement car tous des gens se
rassemblent au plateau où il est
susceptible de le contacter partout où
il chante et un parler ou qu'on ne
respectent pas les mesures de sécurité
il y aura de la contamination personnes
les plus vulnérables ont déjà été
vaccinées et le vaccin est vite les
fameux grave de la maladie mais avec des
grands rassemblements il y aura plus de
contaminations malheureusement donc on
ne change rien pour boris johnson les
britanniques qui sont appelés d'ailleurs
à vivre avec le virus
c'est un parti pris est-ce que c'est
audible pour un scientifique que vous
êtes
yes we camp prix c'est le wait because
there is no sign pas vraiment fière
qu'on peut vivre avec le virus ce n'est
pas comme la grippe a c'est un virus
plus dangereux rose l'europe de l'est
bon mais rappelé que là il faut un vrai
mais il faut vivre est une façon aussi
sûrs et sécurisés
donc il faut maintenir ses mesures qui
empêchent la domination pour vous même
et pour les autres il ne veut pas vivre
avec et en courant le risque de tomber
l'action google buzz que même si l'on
tombe malade est consommé il peut rester
là ce qu'on appelle un kobe de long elle
ne le savons pas combien de temps peut
durer le gouvernement donc la meilleure
stratégie est de ne pas être contaminé
vous ne pas contaminer autrui d'être
très prudent et de maintenir les
sécurité est clairement un aveu d'échec
la part du premier ministre britannique
et d'une certaine manière un aveu
d'échec des politiques de santé des
gouvernements est ce que on arrive
réellement aujourd'hui à lutter contre
ce virus comme quelqu'un de plus en plus
difficile le royaume-uni est en bonne
posture car nous avons largement
vacciner abandonner les mesures de
sécurité les mesures de contrôle de la
contamination il l'aurait du court
termisme
le premier ministre john l
rendre les gens heureux la faire plaisir
mais parfois les personnalités
politiques temps prendre les décisions
difficiles en populaire par exemple il
faudrait décider que partout où on se
trouve dans des moments lieux où il ya
beaucoup de gens dans un supermarché
dans le bus
dans la foule il faudrait porter le
masque afin de se protéger soi même et
les autres banques année vous avez
toujours dit que l'élève
sain et efficace contre les variants du
coc vide notamment le delta mais on voit
en ce moment qu'on y seraient inquiets
quand même aussi l'un des pays les plus
avancés concernant la vaccination est
bien on assiste justement un rebond de
ces contaminations est ce que ça remet
en cause l'efficacité de ce vaccin
il ya tout cela
les rugueuses je suis effectivement un
courant de cette l'efficacité il
légèrement réduite contre le variant
delta existant en israël mais le vaccin
qui protège toujours et le vaccin est
vite l'hospitalisation et les formes
graves de la maladie
righi effectivement une légère réduction
de l'effectif cas cités car le virus est
bien plus contagieux c'est d'ailleurs
pour toi je pense qu'il est allé bien
d'être vaccinés il est également bien
connu et malgré tout à porter le masque
et assurer une bonne ventilation pour
éviter la contamination
merci barak pas au kenya expert en
maladies infectieuses avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france